can I get a round of applause we got a
Tony nominee in the house whoa this is a
hell of a studio audience I gotta tell
you thank you thank you I mean come on
Tony nomination that's it pretty
exciting it's so exciting it's it's very
surreal it's very heady man I uh I mean
I I think I really believe in our show
and she loves me and I really do think
that we've created something special but
you don't know if everybody else thinks
you've created something special until
this kind of stuff happens and yeah it's
really it's really really nutty and it's
only my second Broadway show so to be in
this kind of conversation with these
other incredibly talented guys I think
that it was with anything like this you
got a you receive it and you're grateful
for it and but you can't you still got
to kind of take it a little bit with a
grain of salt because because Hamilton's
not nominated since the juggernaut
that's gonna sweep it all and it's also
you know it's amazing show yeah I know
you from the West Coast did you have
dreams of Broadway oh yeah oh no no I
grew up I grew up doing nothing but
Feder my grandma drove me and my younger
sister up for auditions for Oliver that
was the first one we did and then I did
Wizard of Oz and big river and anyway
yeah I mean yeah of course I mean I knew
of Broadway I Broadway's like you know
the kind of that's that's the that's the
highest level that you could get to and
how cool would that be but just getting
to Broadway is a dream like wow this is
my job is what I get to do but then to
be recognized in this way it's super
nuts meanwhile you also still have each
other week to do and you get each other
each time yeah is it like when you do a
movie and then you're done with the
movie a month if four months yes
you know you might even be working at a
whole nother movie at this point and you
get nominated for an Oscar or whatever
not that I've ever had that experience I
just know that's kind of how that that's
tough times out uh yeah with this you're
still doing the job that you've been
nominated for which is kind of cool and
also kind of weird grounded though
because you still have to work right
yeah I mean again that's why I think you
got to take a list of the grain of salt
it doesn't change your job your job is
to show up every day and prepare
yourself and you know and then warm up
if you're doing musical I don't know
maybe people warm up and they don't do
leather yellow leather all that stuff
the Human Torch was denied a baby
but follow us she loves me the only
second Broadway show but an amazing cast
full of Broadway that's right oh yeah
how much fun is it that show uh it's
awesome when you have an audience that's
with you there's nothing like it when
you have an audience it's kind of quiet
you feel a little more drained because
you know well I don't know I don't maybe
not everybody but I'm I try to give
everything I have and leave everything
out on the stage and with the comedy
it's very it's very you know symbiotic
especially for the comedy with any well
with any show it's symbiotic you feed
the audience and they feed you back and
with the drama it's a little different
because you're hoping that everyone's
very very quiet the whole time but with
a comedy you're hoping that they're
laughing and enjoying it and showing
that laughter an enjoyment so it's yeah
it's it's it's hard but it's enjoyable
and yeah dude I'm like the sophomore who
got pulled up on the all-star team I
mean it's like Benanti Laura Benanti
Jane Krakowski
Gavin Creole Michael McGraw Byron
Jennings Peter Bartlet Nick barish is 17
he plays Arpad and he's had one more
Broadway show than I have I'm like that
just doesn't seem it's like a master
class to attend yeah kinda you know but
one that I'm they both trusted me enough
to give me the job
you find that a lot of shots and yeah
men lots of different lots of different
folks who come out to see the show and
by the way from you know people come
from out from Australia and the
Philippines and Germany and France we
had scheduled last night like they said
we come from France so it's very
humbling to me it's it's really kind of
an honor that people will fly from
halfway around the world to come see you
perform live on the stage and they'll
pay that that kind of money for that
ticket in that experience and so it's
pretty awesome but yeah Chuck fans and
tangled fans and I did a show a couple
years ago called first eight and a lot
of first eight fans that come back
around as an actor or as an artist
that's all you can hope for is that
you're doing work that people care
enough that they want to continue to
support you and follow you and you know
because artists are the first to go and
the zombie apocalypse we don't we don't
actually offer anything other than hey
let's be happy I dig a ditch less you
voice a Disney character you might be
safe for life is it true
right I think I have some kind of like
safe harbor I in a Disney park oh yeah
there's a spot in the bulb there's a lot
of security rose absolutely yeah